I remember the first time that we came
to the Warner Brothers lot we had moved
here from LA we came to the Warner
Brothers lot you guys were shooting
I think hangover 2 right next door right
yeah in 16 right yeah yeah and I was
thinking about it you were right across
really just this narrow alley from us
and I was thinking about it you've had
this amazing career for Oscar
nominations but I bet still when you
walk through an airport people are
hounding you still about hangover right
a little bit yeah yeah because those
movies are I mean they hold up and
they're out there playing constantly
yeah I was in what's that yeah that just
keeps trying to leave yeah I was in we
just finished this regional tour and
where you go around the country which is
actually my favorite part to actually
take the movie and go to cities right
and at the hotel hangover 3 was on I
watched it so that's so funny because
that's what anyone else would do it's
just weird that you're doing and it
holds up mr. Chow was so good yeah yeah
ken Jeong crusty you have in this film I
think one of the reasons one of the
things that interrupt you one more time
yes somebody what somebody's become a
real director yeah
go ahead go ahead when I'm just thinking
about what I did this movie American
sniper where I played Chris Kyle and he
came on your show he had been yeah and
he had been on our he had been on our
show that's right yeah he came on your
show and I watched that because when I
was I didn't have the good fortune of
meeting with him I only talking on the
phone way and so I watched that
interview so many times and that was
actually a great interview it was it he
was terrific yeah he was a terrific
guest and when when he passed that was
it was it's always shocking when
someone's on the show and they go way
too early it's a shocking thing but I
remembered him being a terrific
interview yeah yeah so that's that's
interesting that I mean I watched it
like a hundred times an interview yeah
so so you must have picked up on every
one of my tip everyone that guy's got in
lips that's not a tick no no that's not
a tick that's a horrible thing I was
born with you and me both bro
yeah yeah I know neither one of us
didn't get a lady yeah
puffy lips we really wouldn't have known
Andie's get so much [ __ ] injected into
the clips right I'm like the Octomom
yeah
you